hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I was
trying to make this video already in
fact I recorded a whole bunch and I know
exactly what I'm gonna show you guys but
then my computer just blew up the
recording was lost to the ethos gone
forever and now I have to do it again
but the good news is I know exactly what
to show you because you may be asking me
from your comfortable chair in your
comfortable home why aren't I building
my own home on my new island that I just
discovered and I would ask you in return
which island should I build it upon
that's right the worst kept secret in
all of subnautica I found another Island
and literally it's another island and
it's not a floating island and I'll show
it to you in a little bit but I gotta
get through the new names on the list
here so Colby stone said mark you need
to make a farming tray from the island
you should be able to scan them and you
can put them in your bases which is good
for getting food in the future so Colby
ston your honor you're on a locker and
then Santos Gomez be careful because
this creature can open gates in the
ocean that can teleport you back to the
beginning now I don't know what Santos
is talking about but it's sounds
horrifying and I don't want to run into
that creature might be the sea Emperor
and then :
Stannis kiss or colons Collin Stan call
it : oh god what am i dive so sorry
Collin Collin Stannis kiss said wait
until he runs into sea dragon Leviathan
and that doesn't sound good at all is
that the creature that can open gates
and teleport me back to the beginning of
the game cuz that doesn't sound good at
all so anyway thank you guys so much for
commenting and now I'm going to get to
the next place that I need to go but I
need my seamoth to do it I don't know
why I left it behind hello baby
can I get in you please and thank you
okay
but there's another thing also that I
found and I'm really disappointed that
like my recording doesn't break all that
often but what it does it's always when
I find the coolest things because I went
back let me just breach the surface here
for a little bit ah Bousquet
so I went back to my my little life pot
there whatever you want to call it and I
actually have the welder now so I
repaired it and when I repaired it there
was another device in there that I had
not seen before and I think they added
in an update to the game and you guys
are gonna see it's no longer smoking and
dying in there in fact it's actually
really interesting because this thing
has been drifting it's literally been
drifting across the ocean because it
didn't used to be above the kelp forest
it did not it used to be on its own in a
lovely place not here but now it is
oddly out of place but anyway that's not
the point the point is I can see
everything room here and this is the
direction of the new island but we're
gonna get to that so I went in here and
there was this thing called a
communications relay and when I opened
it or when I clicked on it there was a
weird message that said I had been
staying too long in the midnight reef or
something like that it was really weird
and I don't know why someone would be
talking to me but it got me thinking why
am I the only survivor of that massive
giant giant ship enormous ship it's huge
god damn it why can't I stay on top of
this thing it's huge but this thing is
freaking huge whoa what the hell whoa
whoa whoa easy there what the hell okay
then Oh God
I didn't mean to do that oh Jesus I'm
just tipping it overboard every time I
go on the go man there we go
well that was bizarre I don't think the
thing wants me to think too much about
the conspiracy theories about this but
why am I the only survivor on the only
life pod of that ship literally I'm the
only survivor even before it exploded
Karen said that there were no life
readings on that ship or there were
scattered life readings but those were
the aliens on there so what happened why
am I the only one and why is there no
one else anywhere around here
it's a good question right one to think
about and as I was exploring near the
sound which we're gonna head to right
now there was another interesting detail
that I found and it was that there are a
lot more wreckages around the map than I
thought there was if you know um when I
went out of the mushroom caves early on
in my series I can't believe I've been
doing about twenty episodes this I never
imagined that I'd be playing this game
for this long but there's so many cool
things because whenever I go out into
the ocean here whenever I drift whenever
I see whenever I explore a new area now
that I can go deeper I can actually see
all the areas that I'm get going to I
find new things constantly non-stop I
find new things because I'm actually
able to go down into the depths like
deeper and this isn't even deep but I'm
able to go down way way way way down
high Sancho how are you doing but I'm
able to go so far down that I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure if I continually
explore and I've got a map pulled up
with the game here I can actually see
different areas there's like inert lava
pits or lava whatever you want to call
them there's inert lava places and these
oh yeah these things the floating
islands these giant bulbous things are
actually what are keeping the island
over on the other side of the map up so
it's bizarre because that's over there
but these are over here and there's a
whole bunch of them there's aw there's
literally tons of these floating and
here yeah this was it this this school
thing yeah this was the thing oh there's
so cool I already explored it because
there's nothing inside this so there's
nothing really to get but the fact that
this piece of wretched wreckage got
blown out from the Aurora hello
got blown out from the Aurora and landed
perfectly on these two floating islands
and that's amazing that's like really
amazing I mean I know the developers put
it there I'm not an idiot but it's just
really really cool it's just cool to
have that kind of detail in there the
fact
what is it Lukie well I forgot that I
was in the middle of the ocean and it
turned to goddamn night didn't it okay
I've lost my bearings and I don't know
where I am am I going up I hope do I
hope I am okay so we're gonna yeah turn
night god damn it why is it always gotta
be night okay but I'm getting close see
as soon as I can see where the aurora is
oh there it is I don't even have to show
you I don't even have to get my bearings
so this is what I'm talking about there
is a completely different Island and I
don't know how I miss these things
they're so obvious this thing is huge
it's an oh it's jutting out from the
thing but if you go too far away from it
you won't see it but this it's so cool
it's so cool it's just and this one's
even different because it's not a
floating island this is literally just
land jutting up so it's like a island in
the traditional sense that we'd find on
earth here so it's a guess it's not that
special but it's special to me because
it's so weird and on this island are the
same little skittering crabs that are
found on the aurora which makes me
wonder why are there land animals
anywhere around here like what is the
point of that and that's actually pretty
convenient that the seamoth actually
cast a shadow like that so in here I
actually made a terrible error and I'm
glad you guys didn't see the only thing
that I liked about this thing crashing
is I made the stupidest mistake that I
could have possibly made when I went in
here and this by itself is cool because
it's like an inside little cave here
filled with rich detail and stuff and
you can break these open and you get
not only had gold in it but you can
get your rhenium out of some of these
which is good and diamond I guess
diamonds good but who am I gonna give it
to gold gold yeah see this creeps me out
like I don't like it down here this is
okay
I guess we're just gonna pretend like
that didn't happen what is that what are
you what are you
oh you're tiny but you're glowing
oh you do backflips he actually provides
light that's so cool I didn't even
notice that guy before because what I
did last time is I drowned okay I
accidentally came down here and I
couldn't find the way out and then I
drowned like an embarrassing
son-of-a-bitch
anyway that just leads back to outside
so I don't need to go down there right
now if I can just get at back Frick
Frick dude find it now gold
nothing but gold surrounded by gold and
diamonds I don't even know what the
diamonds are gonna be fly II stop that
up kick your ass buddy from here to
Tuesday yeah you better run you're dead
end dead okay Bank gold gold gold gold
who needs it uranium there so I got
uranium and now uranium can be used in
the nuclear reactor which is a research
module Rob it's a scannable thing I
don't know if I have it yet I don't know
if I ever got it but I might have and
that can provide like unlimited power
from my base which is gonna be used when
I do this and also I know is this it
looks like Pride Rock from The Lion King
that little outpost right there and that
little shut up I think that I'm pretty
sure that's Pride Rock also there is a
path upwards to the top of this mountain
and they're once again the reason I know
all this is because I recorded this
episode already I did all this I had
some really funny jokes no I didn't I
never have any funny jokes but you can
believe that I had some funny jokes when
I was recording oh yeah and birds
it's got birds well I mean they're not
really Birds they're like flaps of skin
like just floating in the air it's
rashly really disturbing but we'll find
more of them and I can actually I can
actually kill one I think because when I
sliced him I haven't been able to kill
one but when I sliced it like I got
spurts of blood to come out of it which
I'm assuming means that it's dying and
those aren't just tickle fluids coming
out with it nope yeah see I can't get
one they just fly away too they run away
why do they always run away come back
come back to me why won't they love me
oh hello
hi that guy loves me too much okay but
also at the top of this mountain here is
a lovely view of the Aurora and it would
have been great if I if I came over here
when this like before the Aurora blew up
I would have loved loved loved loved to
see it from this vantage point and
there's no other way up to go so I can't
go any higher on this but I'm gonna wait
until daylight so that you guys can see
how cool this actually is because you
haven't been able to see much of the
island but now that's coming today
you're gonna see maybe it can nab one of
these suckers are you doing in there you
wanna kill bruh there we go
okay and it's now day oh you you yes yes
yes yes yes yes
ah come on oh oh oh I'm sorry well it's
kind of sad now that's really sad why
did I do that
oh it was a bird oh it even looks like a
bird no no he's spiraling into death oh
the poor bastard okay well that was sad
I don't know why I did that but anyway
alright then okay so this is what I was
talking about this is super cool you can
even see the fish you can even see the
fresh and there's no way up to go I wish
I could go higher to the top of this
mountain but I can't figure out a way to
do that unless I hop on one of those
jumpy bastards but yeah and also the
gravity is just a little weird when you
jump off of here it doesn't quite
doesn't 100% work out the way it's
supposed to maybe the group
oh hi wow you were real okay
I'm gonna get out of here thank you very
much I didn't know there was one of
those things over here oh god it's a
bitey
hello is this ooh is this the home of
those things is this island their mating
ground and up and run into a bunch of
baby ones okay so with that being said
I'm gonna start exploring the different
areas in this new and exciting place
because if I go to the north where no
west-northwest i'll get past the
floating islands and then i'll get into
the mushroom forts which is actually
deeper than i could explore before and
i'll see a lot of really cool things so
I'll be right back when I get to the new
area so see it a bit that is cool
whoa that's a big one what the hell holy
crap oh my god whoa okay actually this
is actually big oh that one's massive if
that one had a few more floaters on it
it could actually be like the island
floating above but you got to imagine
that island is huge there's got to be a
lot of floaters that are working their
butts off trying to keep that off the
ground okay anyway I'll be back but I
mean okay III just have to keep talking
because this is so amazing this is what
I was talking about like I went on a
huge rant and I'm about to go on a huge
rant again about how cool this is
that I can go through the ocean and find
new things everywhere I go literally I
can go anywhere in this ocean whoa hello
hi oh it's a giant pile of sand
I was I was surprised by a giant pile of
sand it looked like something at whose a
giant pile of sand anyway so I can go
through this ocean and I can be
surprised by a gem well oh wait
oh cool
Oh Oh these okay this is one of the
inert lava beds okay this is what it was
talking about
there were like inert lava streams you
can see like little bits of glowy lava
coming through okay so that's cool we've
officially reached where my last
recording stopped but I wanted to go in
here because there are just some
ridiculously cool things oh no II know
this isn't deep enough oh yeah I was
deeper than this so there's got to be um
I know there's got to be something
there's got to be like a drop-off
connected to this somewhere and I'm
going to find it on Urfa I believe that
I can cut these mushrooms right pretty
sure I can I don't know if there's any
use to them there's a lot of items that
you can get in this game that don't
actually have use yet like you can
scavenge a lot of things that don't
actually combine with everything else
yet because they're still working on the
game they're still building the game in
and they're updating it all the time in
between the last episode in this one I
think there actually was another update
although I think it was just minor stuff
but they're constantly adding new stuff
to the game and I would I'd be shocked
to find out that I actually found
everything was is well hello sudden drop
off into No hey how's it going there
it's another one oh cool oh cool whoa
oh that's the self there's a lot of crap
on the ground what is that that's an
upgrade module is that just a plain old
upgrade module Cyclops bridge fragment
okay get some of these no apparently I
got that already yeah alright whatever
okay cool hello
are you doing is there anything in this
one cuz it seemed to be a lot more boxes
oh hello hi anybody home
cargo
well the leases is more populated than
the other one okay cool so quiet and dad
I think that's just a sand chart so I
don't need to worry about that
that's all broken well that's no good
that's all stopped up for having a whole
bunch of boxes in here it's just as
empty as the other ones there's nothing
in here as a whole lotta nothing
something in here whoa hello it's
another human morning oh god I forgot
but look at that it's a picture of
another human I haven't even seen
another human in all this I was
wondering why I was the only one alone
finally find a picture of a human woman
sprawled dead but you know that's
interesting though huh okay so cool I
mean I don't know if there's anything
important in these wreckages just yet
but I do want to find that cave opening
so I'm gonna keep exploring see you in a
bit hello that's not a good sound that's
the opposite of a guy that's a good
sound
okay all right running away oh I think
it spotted me oh this ain't good
oh it's not good opposite of good what
is that what is that what is that
they follow me Oh what is what is this
ooh
oh hello it's a hole in the ground who
God uh Oh God
okay what oh god why is it all bumpy ah
I feel wrong ha oh my god where is this
is this the one oh hello what are you
doing down there are you just following
to you oh my god they're just falling
why did you come down here what is this
I've never seen a biome like this yeah
it feels wrong and I like it it's
probably the Leviathan breeding ground
okay the only reason I'm going out is
because I am out of time for this
episode and I want to make sure that
this episode actually recorded before I
go into any new territory because I told
that do it again so so many times I can
be amazed by the same things but that is
weird
Leviathan still out there okay so I've
got 51% power I'm pretty sure that's
enough for my seem off but Wow
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching in the next episode I'm
gonna find out where this hole goes we
may be down but thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
none will survive my onsen ow gosh
you